America, America.
There are those who say it was Christopher Columbus who discovered it five centuries ago,
and others say it was the Vikings five centuries before that.
It's all true, but the real first Americans, ah, that's another thing altogether.
Alaska and Siberia were joined then, not separated as they are today.
A period of cold back then transformed the sea into ice and snow,
and the sea level dropped by 300 feet.
Do you realize?
Over on the other side, in Siberia, lived a lot of people like us.
You can help me to make a needle.
Now you hold on.
There's nothing to eat, but pretty soon the hunters will be back, I promise you.
Ask grandpa for a bone.
Okay.
Be patient, the hunters won't be long.
The animals are getting away.
I'm bringing much meat today.
Shh!
Let me in, please take a look.
Look, there's only one thing that means we won't have any...
All the others gone.
You tell us you found all that.
Take some back.
The others are hungry too, here.
To carry it if you want?
No, I would just as soon that it'd be him.
Plenty of game.
Most of times when I was younger, if you had known those days spring on me, he was enormous with teeth like sabers.
Women ran away, we were alone.
Tiger and I stared back into his eyes.
I knew he was in for a fight and then he leaped right on me, giant leap.
I dodged him, I was upon me, I seized his tail, I whirled him around, then sent him crashing into a rock.
Remember too, there are no animals around.
Yes, they've all gone away.
There's no good pasture land.
All the grass, they're very big.
Are we gonna starve?
No, there's no reason to worry.
We'll follow the animals, we'll take their direction.
We won't put it together because tomorrow, we're on the move again.
Long we have walked toward the rising sun and have always found more animals and that is what we will do this time.
Friends migrate if they found big animals and they knew.
Yes, well, do they get these animals or not?
Patience. We shall see what we shall see.
And dangerous.
We're the two gods.
We spear the mighty creature. We'll show you how we did it.
Listen, all of you.
All killed it together.
Together we're strong.
One hunter who's all alone is too weak.
All together we're strong enough to hunt any game.
Tigers or the big grizzly bear.
Or even the gray wolf.
Any of them.
You see, hunting together,
we can kill the biggest animal.
It doesn't go away until the sun returns.
It's returned once again.
The animals have all left, we'll have to go to.
Go where?
Warming sunrises, the animals have all gone that way.
Alright, we'll get ready.
That way, I will not go with you, I have come to the end of it.
I have known many lands, crossed many rivers and mountains, I have hunted wild game.
It is time to sleep now, to sleep of eternity, and you'll leave me.
No! Come, Elder, we still have new lands we haven't seen.
There are rivers we haven't crossed.
Oh.
It was from one season to another, from one generation to another,
The first Americans trudged on to the east, following the animal herds.
They had no idea where they were, where they were going.
In fact, they were at a place that we call today the Bering Straits.
But as I told you earlier back then, it was not all water as it is today.
No, the deep cold had frozen it into ice and snow,
and the sea level had dropped by 100 meters, 300 feet.
It meant there was an earth bridge.
It was, we just thought it was a good way to show you it was an important event.
He's got a nice rabbit, only I couldn't quite bag him.
You always make up hunting stories, but the children are hungry.
Better go back, because now he's finding a place to camp.
We're going back. It's a wall of ice.
You, all the animals killed belong to us all.
Twice morsel. He was a good one.
And with the guts, we can make bow strings, bones for tools, and the skin will keep us warm.
We'd live better.
Men wait here and see the fish as they come.
Right? You understand? On your way.
Big C.
He's left to hunt. We have to move on.
Follow the herds again.
and there isn't enough game.
We can't stay.
We can move on.
Only where would we go?
We might go that way,
only there are many other people
and not much game.
That way.
But there's no grazing land,
so there won't be animals.
Or that way.
It's my choice.
That's the way we should go.
He's right, he's right.
Let's do it.
Sure he's right.
It's the only way.
No, no, no.
We don't agree at all.
No way.
We're not going in that direction.
No, and he slapped me on the back
and we're not gonna go with him
no matter what.
No.
Do your own thing.
That's my motto.
No, we're too many together.
if we separate it into smaller ropes.
How's that?
Thousands and thousands of years
for that wall of ice to melt
the great barrier that blocked their way
into this new continent.
By now, behind them, the sea had closed in,
and there they were,
the first Americans
on the threshold of the promised land.